[Music]
it is an art to make this doll because
when you spend many hours making
something that people enjoy it becomes a
masterpiece that is what makes it all
worthwhile fresh pasta is more of a
special occasion you have to practice at
it it's a labor of love it smell the egg
when you cook it and you can taste the
egg and the flour it's pretty damn good
[Music]
i think of what my father used to say
if it's an egg noodle that means you put
eggs in it
when you're making like a fresh egg
noodle doll
with a machine where you now have to put
it together it involves you know using
your your hands your mind and your heart
we like to maintain quality
without raviolis and egg noodles and the
only way you could do that is by using
quality ingredients
you really need to understand the dough
understand the weather is it too wet is
it too dry do i add water do i add a
little more flour
basically have to be consistent with
that though
that machine came from italy it's been
in the store since 1950 i like to say
sometimes i'm part of that machine in
order to make that be the quality we
want when we sell this
for the most part the pasta that we make
and sell is taken back to the home and
i think the significance of something
like that is where unlike a store bought
packaged pasta the texture the flavor is
going to be different it has that
homemade quality taste as if they were
there maybe making it with their
grandmother
[Music]
my grandmother had some recipes making
pasta at home and in 1935 they opened up
bugatti's ravioli and egg noodles this
is actually the recipe of course my
grandparents were using when they opened
up the store
it is an art to make this doll because
uh you're involved with creating it kind
of designing it finishing it using your
hands your mind and your heart
pasta should feel very soft but yet
strong it becomes a masterpiece
we hear 82 years i came into the picture
around 1976 as an 18 year old i think of
it as
a dream
of my grandparents i'm just you know
fulfilling their dream
it is a passion of love because when you
spend uh many hours standing in making
something that people enjoy a customer
come back and say i've had your noodles
i can't imagine ever buying packaged
pasta ever again when you hear things
like that that is what makes it all
worthwhile
i always think of like when it comes to
food
when we think about pasta
it's something that brings us together
we share good times and
good moments you know
i used to come here when i was young
help out putting raviolis together and
packing raviolis and when they first
opened up the store in order to shape
the raviolis they didn't have a machine
they were actually making these raviolis
near the window of the store so people
could see what was going on in this
store
when they were selling them in 1935 when
they opened up a hundred little pieces
only questioned about it one dollar
my father used to say use good quality
ingredients focus on the past what got
you here
what made this place what it is so
always be mindful of that
it started out as a family business
continues as a family keeping it simple
because at the end of the day am i doing
it to make the money or am i doing it
because i know when people sit down to
this
they'll say these are the best raviolis
i ever had in my life
with pasta is it's something that brings
us together i mean there's a variety of
different ways noodles could be served
these days it's not always the same way
you just feel good and go oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
pasta is everywhere and italian food is
everywhere but good pasta is something
hard to find because
there's so many nuances in eating pasta
you have to really focus on the equal
parts of flour and egg yolk
i grew up in wisconsin in a norwegian
family and so food was very very
important always you know whether it was
breakfast or dinner there was always
something going on in kitchens when i
started cooking there was no food
network or it wasn't on tv like it is
today i remember watching ian ken cook
and great chefs on the discovery channel
as a young person i was in college and
made a decision that after a football
injury that i was going to become a chef
and when i told my father that he said
that's fantastic but how do you expect
to make a living
i started in the kitchen just to kind of
see if i really liked it and i remember
they're going their first day and being
mesmerized by eggs and flour coming
together and be something such as pasta
needless to say after the first day i
was ready to roll
probably one of the things that
attracted me the most was coming in
early in the morning working with pasta
it's something that i can get my hands
messy with
never forget that cooking is a vocation
it's something that you use and you do
with your hands
[Music]
obviously i love fresh pasta i don't
want people to think there's anything
wrong with dry pasta either but fresh
pasta in some instances is more of a
special occasion it's a labor of love it
doesn't happen instantly you have to
practice at it it's like doing anything
you have to do enough repetition to know
that when you touch it feels right it
feels dry it feels humid i can look at
something and give it a spray of water
because i know it needs it those types
of things all come with time
[Music]
i'm still perfecting my craft and we're
constantly pushing boundaries of pasta
we're having fun
[Music]
the garganelli for example is a dish
that there's an old story about how
garganelli became garganelli is they
were all laid out over the the uh the
work surface
and there was tortellini pieces of meat
put on every one of the squares a little
cat ate all the filling off the squares
and so the chef was sitting there with
all these squares of puss and she didn't
know what to do so she grabbed a comb
and she rolled them over a comb so
that's how that pasta happened
now i don't know if there's any
real truth to that story or not but it
sounds great
we toss it very simply with uh
prosciutto and cream and parmigiano the
beauty of that pasta is the fact that it
absorbs the sauce quicker you'd smell
the egg when you when you cook it and
toss whipped cream and you taste the egg
and the flour so there's it's all in the
details
to sit down and eat a complete meal with
pasta it's something i don't do all the
time
but it's pretty damn good
[Music]
pasta is something that is the
cornerstone of the altamare group
business it's a cornerstone of what i do
it's what people come to the restaurants
for pasta has fulfilled so many of my
dreams already knowing that people are
coming to eat your food that's pretty
cool these people like came in a train
like an hour and a half from work they
go an hour and a half back like you
better pinch yourself right it's really
really something and those types of
things are what keep me driving to make
pasta as close to perfection as we
possibly can
we really make sure that we're cooking
for the people that we have in front of
us the person behind the stove cooking
the pasta has to be passionate about it
and this is a pasta that is uh with bone
marrow braised octopus red wine tomato
and basil proud of that dish and at the
same time you know we'll never be able
to take it off so you're only as good as
your last pasta dish that's what we like
to say i don't know anything else either
though do you know what i mean it's just
kind of what i do
[Music]
my 29th year cooking in the kitchen
i've worked with my father close to 40
years
the most important thing really is not
about stars it's not about that i want
to continue the story of my father mario
it's about teaching now showing and
making connection with young people in
the kitchen
as a merchant he was always there for
others and he was always giving
me rest in peace
[Music]
[Music]
you